this is a production of cornell
university
now the talk today is really uh what i
call my
book talk and uh this first slide here
is uh i took this it's not photoshopped
or anything like that there's a picture
of detroit
and um it's really a picture of those
trees that surround this uh
this dump area then those of course are
ailanthus trees the tree of heaven
and really what this talk is about is
what
constitutes nature in
in an urban context what does it mean
when we talk about
nature in the city and
so with that introduction um i'm gonna
just sort of jump right in
and as nina mentioned the the second
edition of my book the wild urban plants
of the northeast
uh published by cornell university uh
press it came out in 2020 the first
edition came out in 2010
and you know if you look it covers 267
species so that's an increase of about
20 percent over the first edition but
roughly a third of them
are native to north or
central america 44
come from europe central asia 13 for
east asia that would be china
japan and korea 8 to eurasia and north
america and one percent
to africa so you know the take-home
message here is the vegetation that
grows
spontaneously in our cities it's as
cosmopolitan
as its human population and
uh you know what's interesting is if you
look at sort of
how this has changed there's not that
much data about sort of this
how these um the non-native species
numbers have changed over time but one
source is a famous book asa grey's
manual of botany
the first edition came out in 1856 at
that point
roughly 10 percent of the species agreed
spontaneously
in the northeast were non-native species
by 1890 that
figure was up to about 15 1908 uh 16
and the last edition of gray's manual
came out in
1950 when it was up to roughly 20
so over the period of about 100 years
the
number of non-native species effectively
doubled and
since uh the 1950s now we don't
necessarily break
up the flora in those those terms it's
really something that's
looked at state by state and so for
uh various northeastern states the
percentage of non-native species now
varies from 24
to 35 i think massachusetts has the
highest percentage of non-native species
so
this is uh the presence of non-native
species in our
uh flora is uh you know moving target
this is definitely a trend
and it's not going down in fact it's
increasing
all the time and what's really
interesting is that
i just pulled this chart off of the
internet but if you look at the
you know racial and ethnic composition
of the city of boston and how that's
changed over the last 70 years
you see that you know cities are all
about flux there's no
uh stability and you know with the human
population the flux
uh relates to socioeconomic uh
conditions as they change then
uh you know one ethnic group replaces
another in any given neighborhood and
we accept this as part of the ecology of
cities and with the vegetation
the composition of the vegetation
reflects
changing environmental conditions so
it's really a parallel situation and we
accept you know the diversity of the
human population in cities is a good
thing
but when it comes to the vegetation uh
we we say oh my god it's you know all
these non-natives that's terrible we
have to
do something about it but in fact the
vegetation the ecology of the city
is really just a reflection of uh the
fact that cities exist
for the you know betterment of the human
population
and you know one of the first things you
have to do
when you study urban ecology you have to
define what you mean by urban
so in a traditional definition of 500
people per square mile this is what
you know the north east looks like and
you see when we talk about urbanization
we're not talking about sidewalk cracks
or you know
little patches we're talking about a
major uh
you know force of transforming the
landscape on a
large large scale so urbanization
and it's increasing all the time as a
higher and higher percentage of the
human population moves from the
countryside into
these urban areas so urbanization is
you know essentially is becoming a
geological
force and if you look at you know a
typical modern city i don't know
how many people recognize this is uh
actually los angeles you can see on the
right hand side that
trough there with water running to it
that's the famous la
river and of course you can talk about
um
you know what vegetation used to grow in
the city of los angeles as a historical
uh fact but the concept of what is
native
to la as it currently exists
is a it's a ludicrous question when you
take this
the bird's eye view of the city because
nothing
is native to the city of los angeles
as it exists today and the fact that
people still talk about you know the
native vegetation of cities as though it
were something that
you know was relevant other than as a
historical
from a historical perspective strikes me
as
sort of a crazy idea particularly when
you talk about restoring
the native vegetation of the city and
looking again at cities as you know
ecological entities they have very
specific characteristics that
distinguish them from the surrounding
non-urban areas not the least of which
is
as everyone is familiar with obviously
the urban heat island effect and
along the horizontal axis you have there
the size of the city
population going up to 10 million and
then on the vertical axis
the maximum urban heat island so that's
the difference between
an urbanized area and a non-urban or
rural area
more or less at the same latitude and as
the human
city gets bigger this difference which
is that's in centigrade
so 12 degrees centigrade when you're up
from around a million people that's
roughly 21 degrees fahrenheit
and that's on a warm summer night when
those temperature
differentials are the greatest but
clearly
you know cities are much warmer than the
surrounding countryside and this is
actually an
important uh you know observation
because it means that if you are
interested in studying climate change
effects you
can see them in the urban areas much
more readily than you can in non-urban
areas because the cities
have already warmed up to the extent
that's projected for
future climate change on
in non-urban areas uh other factors that
you know just to make the same point if
you on the left hand side that's the
growing season length for the city of
boston
and then on the right-hand side the land
surface temperatures so
you can see that you know in the boston
metropolitan area there's a good
five to ten days uh difference in
when you know the first frost comes
strictly as a result of urbanization and
the plants this is a you know not
something that's happened you know
suddenly it's been going on for you know
well over 100 years and the plants are
well aware of these changes and this is
what they respond to so
you know adaptation to climate change we
keep talking about climate change it's
something that's
you know about to happen or going to
happen
but in point of fact climate change has
been going on for
quite a long time and the vegetation has
already
adapted to these changing conditions
now the other thing is i've talked about
the definition of urbanization
and i apologize for the complexity of
this graph but it's kind of
it's it's really important this is a map
again i apologize for showing you boston
and not
uh ithaca but there's boston in the very
center and then it's surrounded by
the 95 beltway now the zero point on the
horizontal axis that's downtown boston
and 100 kilometers
to the west represents the harvard
forest in peterson massachusetts
uh very rural where i work used to work
and you know when you get about 19
kilometers outside of boston you cross
95 and each dot there represents
a 100 meter square plot
and it on the vertical axis it measures
the amount of
impervious surface in that 100 meter
square plot
and as you can see that all the sample
plots inside the 95 beltway
were essentially 30 or more impervious
surface and then once you crossed over
95
then basically everything is you know
less than 25
impervious surfaces except for one dot
right there that represents the city of
fitchburg but
why this is important is this means that
you can also define urbanization
uh by the extent of impervious surface
and
when you have 30 percent or more
impervious surface
in a given area you have an urbanized
situation and if it's less than 30
then you can consider that non-urban so
this is a way of talking about
urbanization independent
of the human population so from this
perspective it turns out that many of
our
suburbs are actually from a biological
point of view
uh urbanized and the one the reason that
you know impervious surface works is
that
you know if you've worked at all with
plants you know that when you change the
drainage patterns on the site
you automatically change the vegetation
so
vegetation it responds incredibly
closely to
drainage patterns and impervious surface
is
you know one of the most effective ways
of changing drainage across the site
and when you have more than 30
impervious surface then you essentially
have
an urbanized condition so from a plant
perspective or biological perspective i
should say
i like to define urbanization as you
know 30 percent
or more uh impervious surface and
i like to analogize urbanization with
glaciation
of course the heavy equipment is the
urban glacier and uh you know just like
the
real glaciers uh the urban glacier
leaves compacted
glacial till in its wake and you know
this is
what it looks like after construction
and they call in the landscape crews
they put the
two inches of topsoil on there and sow
grass and
you know you're you're at the prime
state of primary succession
just like you would have after uh the
receding of
the glaciers and you know for again
for boston the urban glacier has
expanded the original land area of
boston by 17
so the uh sort of orange color
represents the original topography of
boston the beige represents
parts of boston that were filled prior
to 1880 and the blue
uh filled after 1880. so then the
question becomes well let me before i go
into that
uh what's interesting so this is you
know this is the history of boston
and i i put this slide here because it's
really important in 1913 fema issued a
high risk for sea level rise for
flooding
and you know everything bordered in red
uh
is going to be okay on one side of it if
it's you know
the bluish color and if it's the pinkish
color that's
in danger of flooding and you can see
that it corresponds almost exactly to
the areas that have been
filled in and so if you're on the
original topography of boston you're
fine but if you're up
you know if your property is on the
field area you've got real trouble now
when this
map came off came out in 1913 the real
estate developers had a complete
fit because they thought that this would
depress the property values so
fema actually pulled the map but it was
it was really too late
information got out there but uh you
know what's really interesting is this
is actually uh
you know sea level rise represents a
restoration if you will of the original
topography
now from a biological point of view the
question
rises what's the name what's the native
vegetation of
phil soils given that almost 20 percent
of boston is built on
fill and uh you know you realize of
course that's a
you know kind of an absurd question but
you know native soils have very specific
characteristics layered distinct loans
of biological activity
typically thin and porous high organic
matter content
low nutrient content high levels of
biological activity and cycling
whereas fill soils no natural structure
heavy and contaminated
low organic matter content high nutrient
content low levels of biological
activity and often
chemically contaminated so you know
these uh you know this the the plants
you can't there's nothing to restore
these fill soils support
a very different palette of plants than
the native soils and
you can't talk about restoring native
ecosystems unless you have
some semblance of the original native
soil intact to work with
but when you uh are working on fill
soils you can't create a native
ecosystem all you can do is create
what's called a
novel ecosystem and you know there are
other
factors that you know uh you know affect
the vegetation at the
urban scale road salt you know we spread
road salt here in boston like there's no
tomorrow nobody wants to compromise
public safety for the sake of
a few plants but very few people are
aware of the fact that
you know with just a mere act of
spreading salt on the ground it
increases soil compaction
decreases water availability reduces
cation exchange the ability plants to
pick up nutrients
and elevates soil ph
and as i said earlier the plants know
exactly what's going on
and have already adapted so one of our
most common urban plants
mugwort artemisia vulgaris comes from
europe from limestone soros
soils in europe and is highly tolerant
of
salt and soil compaction and does
extremely well in the urban conditions
and along our highways which are
salted to within an inch of their life
uh the atlantis tree
does so well because of its uh high
level
of salt tolerance what's interesting
though
is that it's not just the non-native
species that are responding
changing environmental conditions but a
number of our
native species have also responded so
seaside goldenrod that used to be
confined strictly to coastal areas has
moved
inland from boston almost to sturbridge
which is about
sturbridge massachusetts along the mass
pike which is
close to 50 miles and that's all
happened within
the last 30 or 40 years and
um ground soul bush which is a bacarous
that's moved up from
new jersey it used to be uh very
uncommon
in massachusetts but now uh the roadside
ditches
along our our interstate uh are now
filling up with the ground cell bush the
way
uh it used to be in new jersey so it's
not just the
uh non-native invasive species that are
taking advantages but a number of native
species also know what's happening
and are adapting now the other thing
that is
clearly a factor particularly in urban
environments is
you know when you ever burn fossil fuels
that puts uh
nitrogen and sulfur compounds into the
air and then they
come back down either under wet or dry
conditions and we used to call that
you know acid rain but
that's what it still is actually but you
know when these compounds come down they
lower the soil ph acidify the soil uh
through you know by increasing nitrogen
and sulfur
content and this
is been going on for a you know a very
long time and it's a result of the
burning of fossil fuels
all fossil fuels uh result in
ultimately the deposition of nitrogen
and sulfur compounds
but at the local level the acid
precipitation
it interacts with any limestone
structure any concrete
that leeches the calcium out of the
concrete
and it creates higher ph sort of micro
climate
in the vicinity of these concrete
structures so the acid conditions the
acid precipitation
actually creates high ph environments
in the urban uh in cities basically now
this slide
done by a colleague of mine a friend
good friend from boston university so as
part of his phd thesis
this is nitrogen deposition boston this
is kilograms of nitrogen per hectare per
year
and my house which is one of his
research sites right here in watertown
massachusetts was 11 pounds
i should say 11 kilograms of nitrogen
per hectare was the rate so that
averages out to
roughly pounds per acre so we can call
that roughly 10
pounds per acre of nitrogen it's coming
out of the sky
uh on an annual basis
in the boston metropolitan area this is
an astounding number
and this has been going on this is not a
new phenomenon this has been going on
for as long as we've been burning fossil
fuels so well over
100 years the good news is of course is
that you know
you can stop fertilizing your lawn
because that's an awful lot of nitrogen
that's raining down from the sky the bad
news is of course is this completely
changes ecological conditions and those
plants that can tolerate those higher
levels of
nitrogen will do well in those species a
lot of our native species they don't
know what to do when confronted with
this much nitrogen
and they are unable to take advantage of
it so these are
you know and most of this is uh the
source of this it's if you can
fingerprint it
it comes from automobiles
and as you move to the west from boston
it's not a
you know values of nitrogen deposition
much higher in the cities than they are
peter sam
but there's it's not a nice a linear um
relationship it's it's more complicated
than that really depends on how close
you are to a major
highway uh in terms of you know where
that deposition
number is uh so nitrogen deposition is
much higher in cities and non-urban
areas but it's not a
nice linear uh relationship now uh
the question of how does vegetation
respond to this it's a question that
um ecologists have thought about for a
long time and this is a study that
came out of cornell university almost 20
years ago now
and they looked at populous deltoids and
they actually you know got the same
soils they planted
populace and i think ithaca and new york
city and they
you know i was surprised to find that
the trees in new york city grew much
better than they did
in ithaca and it took them a long time
to figure it out some of it was due to
the increased nitrogen deposition
some of it increased temperature but in
in the case of this study
uh they determined that it was the
amount of ozone
uh it was more responsible that ozone is
produced
in the upper atmosphere in above urban
areas but then
wind moves it to a non-urban area so
ozone levels are actually higher in many
cases in the areas surrounding
the city than in the city itself so the
trees did much better
in manhattan than they did in new jersey
partly because of nitrogen but mainly
because of ozone
now when i was working at the arboretum
we did a little
experiment i mean it took almost 10
years basically to do it but
people still don't forgive me for doing
this we did a
a logging experiment at the arnold
arboretum which people were just
horrified at but we had a stand of
hemlock trees it was a native stand
essentially that was
uh being destroyed by a hemlock woolly
adelgid
infestation so rather than just watch
the trees all die it's 24 acre site
we decided we'd do a comparative study
with my colleagues at the harvard forest
and we would cut
a patch of these hemlock trees and look
at regeneration
in the urban area that would be the
arnold arboretum versus
the same experiment done at the harvard
forest a hundred kilometers away so we
did the
logging using a crane a very high end
logging operation
uh at the arnold arboretum in the middle
of
you know to actually towards the end of
winter uh when they would be doing it at
the harvard forest as well
and this is the black birch this is
natural regener
regeneration of bachelor lenta ten
years after the cutting of hemlock hill
at the arnold arboretum moose
the trees were over 30 feet tall which
is just like black birch is
not supposed to be able to grow uh
that fast if you look at the data in the
silva cultural
literature and what we found basically
is that you know
we haven't published this study yet
we're still working on it but that
when you compare the relatively
undisturbed urban soils at the arboretum
this was a natural area
versus the royal or the rural soils the
carbon forest
the soils of the arboretum were more
compacted more acidic
lower carbon than nitrogen ratio
very high levels of nitrogen nitrogen
cycling and you can see that right here
on this graph here
hemlock hill the nitrogen was over 2000
uh you know in the
captured in resin bags that's i don't
know if that's parts per million but
and then sims track and harbor forest is
close to zero
soil ph again uh hemlock hill was three
a sims tac sims tracked it was uh
more like uh 4.2
almost so and the final conclusion was
after 10 years the natural regeneration
of black birch at the arboretum
was significantly more abundant and
larger
than at the harvard forest and
undoubtedly as a result of
the higher nitrogen uh soil content
and the warmer winters it's difficult to
separate those two things apart but
those
seem to be the two factors that explain
the difference in growth and sort of
putting this together
you know almost every study i've looked
at when they're comparing urban and
non-urban areas tree growth find that
the trees in the urban area actually do
better than the trees growing in
non-urban areas and you can see that if
you look at the various factors
increase nitrogen deposition that has
positive effects at first now you can
have too much nitrogen that becomes
negative
soil ph increase growing season
temperature co2 levels
increase growing season length warmer
winter temperatures
impervious surface soil compaction
so the these factors all impact tree
growth and what's interesting is many of
them
actually are favorable uh for the growth
of trees in urban areas
but again if you go too far uh down that
line
it then has a it begins to be
unfavorable so
this is uh you know really really
interesting and it strikes a lot of
people it's counterintuitive that trees
actually grow better in the urban
environment
than the non-urban environment but the
data
suggests um no actually they do
they do very trees do very well in
cities
uh and fragmentation of course is
another
uh characteristic of the urban
environment uh here this is in los
angeles the arroyo seco parkway the one
through the tunnel on the left-hand side
was the original one that was
imagine at four lanes that was both into
and out of the city and within
about 20 years it wasn't big enough so
they built the other
uh highway elevated there just sort of
went right through the middle of the
mountain and completely
uh fragmented the landscape and
you know another word for fragmentation
of course is just suburban
sprawl and you know here's a map for 50
years of
development in massachusetts i'm sure
it's the same for new york state
has been a tremendous increase in the
development both urban and non-urban
over
the past 50 years which results in the
total fragmentation of the landscape
and what's really interesting is we you
know you think about suburbanization and
suburban sprawl
is you know building these these housing
developments and that it was true in the
1950s and 60s
but the way um suburbanization seems to
be happening these days
is that you know they're punching holes
in the middle of intact forest and
putting
houses in with long driveways which that
process is known as
perforation and you know you start by
perforating the landscape and then
over time the perforations come together
and
lead to fragmentation but it used to be
using
satellite imagery when you looked at a
perforated landscape that looked as
though it were
an intact forest but now with more
sophisticated more detailed
satellite imagery we can now recognize
these perforated landscapes as
essentially no longer intact forests and
it turns out that the northeast is
losing its forest cover
at a much faster rate than people
assumed was happening because we weren't
counting this perforation process
as part of the fragmentation
process so again this is this is
happening it's happening on a large
scale
and it's really having an impact on
all of our uh native ecosystems
the thing about fragmentation is that it
creates um
you know edges uh and you know where you
have an
edge um you know you have different
types of habitats coming together and
people who study invasive species if
you're trying to
correlate the occurrence of invasive
species with some
uh environmental factor and you you know
look at a lot of different factors the
one factor that explains
the most about the distribution the
occurrence of invasive species on any
landscape
is proximity to the nearest road
and so the you know roadways with their
disturbed edges disturbed by the
application of road salt and
mowing and so on and so forth are
typically
dominated by non-native species as a
result of all that disturbance and then
from those disturbed edges
this plants will move into the
surrounding forests
and similarly you know the rivers many
of our cities are built along rivers
and rivers also experience high levels
of disturbance due to fluctuations in
the water level
and as a result of this disturbance
albeit a natural disturbance
you typically have a high percentage of
non-native species dominating
these uh river bottom lands in urban
areas because
uh they're adapted to the the you know
it's
either extremely dry in the middle of
summer and then at flood stage in spring
and you have to be a very adaptable
plant to be able to
uh survive those extremes of
environmental conditions
now what's interesting about these
fragmentation
is that you know you think about
transportation corridors railroad tracks
and highways and
traditionally an ecologist would look at
these as
barriers to the migration of you know
animal species and you know they build
these overpasses out in the far west to
help
animals cross these barriers but what's
interesting is in an
urban context these
barriers can also be corridors and this
is actually the flip side of the coin is
that
every barrier is actually also a
corridor so
you know this uh train track here this
is in boston the purple line
it comes up from the south goes and runs
on its way into the forest hill subway
station
it runs right into the arnold arboretum
and once those trains stop running
around midnight
that's free that's that's open to animal
access and so the animals start
moving up and down those train tracks
and you know they get to the arnold
arboretum that way and they've
you know they've arrived at paradise as
far as they're concerned so these
uh transportation corridors after you
know
after midnight uh actually serve as a
very important uh
pathways for wildlife to enter and
leave the urban environment so this is a
good example of
you know how urban ecology works in ways
that's different from the ecology and
the
surrounding non-urban areas now and
getting
back to the vegetation for a minute you
know the the plants that
essentially grow well and do well in the
cities like
i mentioned i land that's not my very
first slide there
here it is on the left hand side that's
growing on the limestone hills
around beijing there it is on the great
wall
and on the right hand side is you know
the same tree
growing in exactly the same conditions
the great wall
near the arnold arboretum essentially
and so
i call this pre-adaptation in other
words the plants that do well in the
urban environment come from
areas in nature that resemble the
habitats
that they uh come from and so they're
they're not adapted so much to the urban
environment as
pre-adapted they come from areas in
nature that resemble
those you find in the city so you know
what is a
you know crumbling brick building from a
tree's perspective
except you know it's a limestone cliff
basically um and you know european
ecologists who are light years ahead of
american ecologists in study of urban
environments
have really based on looking at
detailed analysis of vegetation over 30
cities scattered across europe
that urbanization favors species that
would be plants
that grow well in soils that are
relatively fertile
dry sunny and alkaline so that's your
profile of your typical urban plant
because
those are the types of soil conditions
that dominate the urban environment now
this explains roughly about 60 percent
of the
plants that grow in this spontaneously
in cities fit this profile and obviously
there are some that
you know do not but it does explain
the majority of those plants that grow
in urban environments so that's really
this is
really important information because
this tells you
a lot about the nature of the urban
environment so
pre-adaptation if you begin to look at
this is what types of habitats in nature
do urban plants come from obviously
limestone adapted plants are tolerant of
de-icing salts and concrete rubble
tap-rooted herbs from rocky outcrops
grow well in sidewalk cracks
disturbance adapted early successional
trees have a strong capacity to sprout
back following repeated cutting and weed
whacking
floodplain trees perform well in urban
streets with high light
and compacted soils winter annuals that
germinate in the fall and flower in the
spring are more robust with
warmer shorter winters this is amazing
because i've just watched you know
over the past 20 years the number of and
the abundance of winter annuals and
their size
in the spring when they uh flower and
seed is
really changing and that's one life form
that is
really a big winner when it comes to
climate change
nitrophilic annuals including many
agricultural weeds respond well to
uh atmospheric nitrogen deposition
day length and sensitive plants that
leaf out early in spring and hold their
leaves into the fall
have a much longer growing season than
you know our native
vegetation that's much more dependent on
or responsive i should say to day length
than it is to
temperature and warm temperate species
from southern latitudes that flourish in
the heat island
warmth of northern cities so these are
you know if you begin to sort of
look at what plants do well in the urban
environment
these are the types of habitats in
nature where they come from
now before they get into the next
section of my talk i have a very simple
taxonomy of urban landscapes you'll like
this because it's
you know it's really very basic you know
you have your unmanaged
natural urban landscape so these would
be you know
land dominated by a mix of native and
non-native species on light or
moderately disturbed soil so they might
still have some
semblance of the native soils intact and
of course they require low
to medium maintenance and you have your
managed urban landscapes these will be
parks ball fields cemeteries
dominated by cultivated plants rich
highly modified soils
and of course medium to high maintenance
requirements and then
what i'm going to talk about for the
remainder of this is the ruderal
or abandon urban landscapes
post-industrial land vacant lots
spontaneous vegetation on compacted or
fill soils and of course
highly sustainable because they have
zero to
low maintenance requirements so this is
just a very simple way of categorizing
urban vegetation in response to
soil type and uh maintenance regime
and if you you know if you want to study
urban and vegetation
uh the rust belt uh area of the
united states is one of the best places
and detroit is sort of the poster child
for uh the rust belt um you know the
because abandonment in detroit is you
know began in the
19 actually began in the 50s but really
really accelerated in the 1960s and
you know detroit has lost over 40
percent of um
a huge percentage of its po actually 60
of its population has been since the
1950
so it's from a sociological point of
view the situation in detroit is a
catastrophe they
they need more jobs they need work but
from a
botanical point of view it's really an
interesting place to go because the
process of abandonment
has been going on for you know upwards
of 60 or 70 years now so you get to see
what happens over time
when portions of the city have been
abandoned
and left to nature and this is not
something you're going to find in boston
or new york
uh you know these prosperous cities
where land vacant land doesn't
sit for more than five or ten years
because it's worth so much so in detroit
basically
the land has lost uh its its value and
you know from a design point of view the
question is well what what do you do
with land when it's
lost its value so this graph
shows you you know forty percent of uh
detroit is abandoned some of that is
land some of its buildings and
it's a pretty uh extreme situation and
you know as i said what's interesting
about it is you actually have these
you know cosmopolitan forests have
emerged i
you know i don't like you know i a lot
of these
plants that i study you know suffer from
image problems they're called
invasive non-native they're all these
derogatory terms so
i decided to come up with a sort of a i
tried to
improve the image a little bit by
referring to it as cosmopolitan
vegetation so here's your typical
cosmopolitan forest growing up in
detroit but
you know when you go into some of these
neighborhoods maybe only one or two of
the original houses are still standing
and um it's you know you feel like
you're in the middle of the countryside
basically it's really extraordinary the
vegetation has taken over a lot of the
buildings like there's obviously a
wetland up there on the second floor
where the willow is growing or
you know this is the loading dock
wetland where the drainage no longer
works and the phragmitis has come in and
when i was there in the spring the red
wing blackbirds were in there singing
and it was just a
you know this is an urban wetland no
doubt about it
so what's happening in our cities is
really you know we're watching the
succession process what happens to urban
infrastructure when it's abandoned and
how what's the process
that vegetation or recolonizes the urban
environment and i think it's a you know
this is the modern version of
old field succession that a lot of
people studied uh
way back when and you know once you
begin looking at the urban
environment from this perspective you
realize that fence lines are
you know safe sites for uh seedling
establishment because
the mowers can't get to them and there's
always a a seam there
where the fence is it allows seedlings
to
establish and of course this is the
ultimate manifestation of a
fence as a safe site the maintenance
crews would love to get
rid of this american elm but it's
enmeshed in the chain-link fence
and there's nothing that can be done
about it
and of course the other thing that's
characteristic at the
micro scale is wherever you have
different types of paving material
coming together you have a seam forming
because the materials expand and
contract it differential
differentially in response to
temperatures and because of that these
seams form and the plants
always are able to find those seams and
insert themselves into it and so
this is the trifecta of uh
construction material you've got
blacktop granite and concrete
coming together and that offers
unlimited opportunities for plants or
you know i've showed this slide before
but it's i you know i just love it
because when i took the picture i didn't
know
it just looked weird to me and i took
the picture but if you look at it
closely you see that the grass
is only growing on the short end of the
brick and not the long end and
you might look at this picture and say
did a landscape architect plant this
what's going on
but if you realize that masonry is like
metal
it expands or contracts in proportion to
its length
that the gap that forms uh you know
along the
short end of the brick is going to be
just a little bit wider than the gap
that forms and the on the other side of
the brick and that
difference is just enough to allow the
seeds of this native
species to get in there and germinate so
this is
you know this is the kind of thing
that's happening all over the urban
environment
and you know it's real ecology but
somehow or other
we don't count it as ecology or this is
another example
you turn the air conditioner on in june
uh you get the condensation
that's the beginning of the rainy season
as far as the carpet weed is concerned
we turn the air conditioner off in
september that's the onset of the
dry season they'll see the plant matures
its seeds
it's an annual plant it lays them down
disappears totally and then when we turn
the air conditioner back on adjourn
june they germinate and the whole cycle
begins again
so you know there's real ecology
happening
in the urban environment you just have
to you know
train your eye to recognize it um
and this is uh you know i've used the
term now novel ecosystems a couple of
times but
it really refers to you know an
ecosystem
and that develops in response to
changing environmental conditions that
allow the entry of new species
and lead to the rearrangement of
existing species and
essentially you know back in the old
days you had forest ecosystems if they
were cut
uh or turned into farms they you know
and then abandoned they would revert
back to forests but now if a forest
ecosystem is converted to a suburb or a
city
and then it's abandoned it doesn't go
back to being a forested ecosystem
it essentially becomes a novel ecosystem
so
what happens you know we're seeing now
are these hard landscape
transformations involving paving and
construction
and those hard transformations when they
revert to nature
they turn into these novel ecosystems
whereas
soft transformations associated with
agriculture and logging
they will revert back to a forested
ecosystem
so these novel urban ecosystems have
very specific characteristics
interacting forces urbanization
globalization and climate warming
to stabilize native ecosystems and lead
to the spread of
opportunistic species that's a word i
like both native and non-native
water air ground pollution impact soil
chemistry which impacts microbial
activity which impacts nutrient cycling
and
vegetation patterns so the vegetation is
like the icing on the cake if
you know it's all about the soil that's
really you know
if there's one take-home message you
have from this talk
it's really that you know everything we
do
in the environment ends up essentially
in the soil and the soil is
you know determines vegetation patterns
habitat fragmentation creates sunny
edges which are dominated
by fast growing disturbance and you know
the good news is
is that you know this is this is what is
happening
you know these are these novel
ecosystems of what are happening on a
worldwide basis
associated with all the changes and as i
say the good news is
is that the vegetation has already
adapted
to these changing conditions so we as
people we still may
be arguing about it from a political
perspective
but uh the plants are not paying any
attention to our little
uh political debates and they've just
gone ahead and
adapted to the changing world
in that sense uh you know i i subtitled
my book the
flora of the future because it really
represents
these are the plants that are going to
flourish under the projected changes
that are going to be happening
to our planet over the next you know 20
years or so
and you know if you've come with me this
far on this journey
uh not only do i assert that you know
these non-native species
are not bad i would say that in urban
context many of them are actually
quite positive in terms of the ecosystem
services that they provide i won't go
through this list you can just look at
it and
you know you know if you're looking if a
tree creates shade it's going to
lower temperatures it really doesn't
matter where that plant is from
all plants sequester carbon some are
more effective than others and
you know atlantis sequesters carbon you
know and nobody has to you know plant it
or take care of it so
you know that's highly efficient because
there's no uh
cost associated with its care and
maintenance and let's look at some of
these
cosmopolitan species um
the mulberry uh you know this was
planted a
hot plant in the 1820s when america
thought we could compete with china
for silk production that didn't work out
so well but
the mulberry tree is a legacy of that
period of time the 1820s and it's now
ubiquitous
as a spontaneous plant in the northeast
and you know the kudzu vine we don't
have that in the northeast but you know
you're familiar with it if you're from
the south or you've been to the south
uh you know it's got a terrible
reputation but what people fail to
realize
is that 13 million kudzu plants were
actually
planted subsidized by state and
federal government for erosion control
purposes so
yes it's a it's a it's a you know
a bad plant but we actually planted it
so
when you think about these invasive
species they're not just biological
problems
that was a policy that called for
planting this plant so there's a
sociological component
to the invasive species issue that a lot
of biologists don't want to admit to
it's not just you know bad plants versus
good plants it's no
actually there's good policy and not so
good policy so there's a
you know kudzu was planted as a result
of a
you know government program mainly along
railroad rights of way
um you know other species that are
ubiquitous the robinia which
you know on the top shows a standard
robinhood uncut and then you cut it and
it root suckers like crazy
this is the native range of robinia
before farmers started planting it in
the early 1800s
and you know it's incredibly useful
plant because it produces this rot
resistant wood
that can be used for you know fence
posts and you know any kind of um
wood that has to come in contact with
the ground all of mine timbers in this
appalachian mountains coal mining are
built out of robinia so this was a
you know this was a gift from heaven as
far as the farmers were concerned
because
the post could last 20 or 30 years in
the soil
this is the real range of robinhood
pseudo acacia
you know so yes you can hearken back to
where it was
you know before 1800 but the world has
changed and so yes that's an interesting
historical
frame of reference to think about
robinia but in fact it's incredibly
common in europe and in
asia so you know uh talking about
restoring
the native ecosystem or removing
robinhood because it wasn't native
when the pilgrims landed i think is
crazy
you know the world has changed and there
is no going back
in time or let's look at another one
japanese knotweed you're all familiar
with this
obviously uh you know it was a hot plant
in the 1860s
uh william robinson the inspiration for
frederick law olmsted a lot of his work
um he loved the plant and you know
eventually he
sort of disowned it he said it was too
aggressive but
the first editions of his uh book early
editions he was a big fan of it
and uh of course just incredibly
aggressive and
dominates landscapes where it grows and
i'm not saying that
you know it's not a bad plant it really
depends on the context in which it's
growing here it is along the white river
uh in vermont uh was sort of part of a
much larger ecosystem but then in 2000
and uh i think it was um
i would say 13 there was a hurricane
that came through
and uh essentially wiped out scoured the
white river a basin
wiped out most of the native vegetation
but the cabinet is not weed because it's
got a very deep
taproot essentially was able to survive
and now
both banks of the white river junction
for much white river
are much of its length are dominated by
uh japanese knowledge so this is a
really serious ecological problem that
the state now faces so
you know there's no doubt that some of
these plants have some you know can be
very
destructive but in an urban context
i think the situation is a little bit
more nuanced in it there is hurricane
irene in 2011. i said
2013 but that was uh
i think a couple years before um
hurricane
sandy or you know pirates the bradford
pear it was considered this perfect
street tree
you know for a good 30 years of millions
of them were planted across north
america
and then uh you know lo and behold it
starts spreading away from this
uh you know commercial plantations into
the woods and
oh my god a new invasive species is born
but again you know we have to
acknowledge the sociological component
to the spread of uh the calorie pair or
you know phragmitis this is uh the new
jersey turnpike the um
i think this is the vince lombardi exit
near there
you know you could look at his landscape
and say oh my god it's an incredible
mess
but you know we got to clean it up and
get it back to where
it once was restore it but you could
also say that there's
over a you know history of over 500
landfills in this uh
new jersey meadowlands and that the
phragmitis even though it's not native
is helping clean up the mess
by absorbing nitrogen and phosphorus and
you know yes you could restore this salt
mar
meadow cord grass that used to dominate
the meadowlands
it would actually be pretty simple all
you do is
remove the new jersey turnpike
and restore the title flaw you know
tidal flow
to that area and you'll get that salt
metal cord grass back
but as long as that turnpike is there it
impedes the tidal flow
and what you get is phragmites so a lot
of these uh
so-called invasive species are really
they're they're symptoms of
environmental degradation they are not
necessarily the causes of it and
you know charles darwin recognized that
um you know this isn't actually it's an
evolutionary process
not just ecology that over time
evolution
ecology becomes evolution and you know
one famous study has shown that
actually the invasive species are not
distributed
randomly across the planet that there's
a sort of a
asymmetry and that agricultural and
weeds and weeds disturb habitats
uh originally mostly in europe and have
spread into
eastern north america and eastern asia
where as far as species from eastern
asia have invaded
asymmetrically the forests of eastern
north america and meadows from eastern
north america that would be
you know the great plains have
selectively invaded eastern asia and
and europe so you know this is evolution
that's happening
it's not just you know um
something that's it has real
evolutionary implications and this is i
think
really what we need to focus on it's not
about restoring you know what used to be
here
we really have to own up to what's
happening in the real world
and what are we going to do about how
can we sort of
change this this thing to work for us
in in the future changes dynamic and of
course you know i hate making
predictions but
here they are you know if you begin to
look at you know the forest over time
these are the trends that are happening
you know on a large scale throughout the
east coast
vines are you know becoming much more
dominant and of course pests and
pathogens
uh you know are also becoming
increasingly
uh players in in sort of reshaping our
forests they're taking out
you know whole species think about the
emerald ash borer
you know what how our forests are going
to look once all those ash trees are
removed and
you know vines are incredibly
destructive if you want trees you pretty
much have to get rid of vines this is
bittersweet you all know about
bittersweet and you know but
what's interesting is you know as i said
it's there's a sociological component to
the invasive species issue and
you know if you really want to control
invasive woody plants you pretty much
have to use herbicides now
maybe in the in the rural areas you can
get away with using herbicides
people don't pay much attention to but
in a suburban
and a urban area people are tuned into
herbicides they hate use of herbicides
and if you actually
ask people whether they'd rather have
the invasive species
or you know use herbicides many people
will tell you they they just assume have
the
uh invasive species so you know this is
not just a biological
issue it's really a uh there's a huge
sociological component so the issue then
becomes how do you deal with these
these novel ecosystems as opposed to
just wiping them out
and saying we're gonna you know restore
was here
is you begin to uh you know the process
is called
entalya which is designed uh
by removal rather than insertion so it's
the difference between
editing an article and writing one and
you know the so these
novel ecosystems what you know
horticulturist of the future really have
to learn to do
is how do you manipulate these um
you know these landscapes to increase
their ecological and their aesthetic
characteristics
removing high climbing vines diseased or
damaged trees
trees are unhealthy or unfriendly to
people
unsightly or aggressive plants that
may be perceived as a indicator of
dereliction or neglect
so it's not about eliminating novel
ecosystems but how do we
you know manipulate them to increase
their aesthetic and ecological
functionality and uh you know if
done right it can actually be uh
you know pretty remarkable this is a
landscape um
at the arnold arboretum uh of all places
a
24-acre site that was essentially a band
abandoned
urban infrastructure that is a uh now i
call it urban nature but
minimal intervention and this is my last
slide of course
and so um let's uh i'm sure they're
going to put this
on my tombstone uh you know
what we adapt or die that is really
you know uh the challenge that we face
now not only from an ecological point of
view but
you know we humans uh you know that's
something we we can learn
from uh the vegetation that surrounds us
so thank you very much for
your attention and i think i can uh stop
my screen share
and uh we go to speaker view and i guess
uh
nina you i went over a little bit longer
than i was supposed to but um
do we have time for some questions yeah
well there's some questions on chat here
thank you so much peter
always fascinating to hear yeah
uh okay well how much
was one question is how much sulfur is
being deposited
how much what sulfur as opposed to the
nitrogen
i guess i'm not sure about the sulfur
the
my friend was doing the study was
looking exclusively at the
nitrogen so i would have to uh go back
and do a little bit of research to get
into the
sulfur question uh there's another
question from marvin pritz in the early
1900s new york was only 10 percent
forested due to logging
today they estimate their state is about
55
forested but how much of this 55
would you say is fragmentized
cosmopolitan urban forest or not
secondary forested ecosystems
well again that's you know the satellite
imagery
is really um plays a big uh
role in in answering that and this whole
what's interesting is that this
when they identified this process of
perforation and this was now
about oh maybe 10 years ago or 12 years
ago
all of a sudden the amount of intact
forest you know dropped by
you know i think it was like three or
four percent uh once they were able to
actually recognize it so
um i think that's why i said that very
early that you
if you have 30 you know if you can you
know impervious surface is something you
get off gis
very easily so that is a surrogate for
essentially a novel urban that's
urbanization from an ecological point of
view
so if you were able to generate a
impervious surface map of an area that
would probably give you
a pretty good idea of how much of the
landscape was actually dominated by
a novel ecosystem yeah that's
uh and i also say fantastic presentation
from somebody so
um i guess that's about it for our
questions
all right and uh i'd rather say thank
you and we are we have recorded it so
that
all that information will be available
in uh
one of the sips portals so thank you
peter it's been a pleasure
thank you it's always great to uh
come to cornell even virtually and
you know deliver the message right brave
new world
thank you so much oh you're welcome
bye-bye okay bye-bye
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu